RACHEL: WITH MORE THAN 2 MILLION
BORDER CROSSINGS THIS FISCAL
YEAR, THE HIGHEST ON RECORD,
WE'RE LIVE IN DEL RIO, TEXAS,
THIS MORNING TO GET THE
FIRSTHAND ACCOUNT ON HOW BIDEN'S
BORDER CRISIS IS AFFECTING BOTH
THIS COMMUNITY AND THE COUNTRY.
JOINING US NOW NATIONAL BORDER
PATROL COUNCIL AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND HOST OF DARK
WARS, THE BORDER.
CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR THE PODCAST.
SOUNDS EXCITING.
I'M GOING TO START WITH YOU,
BRANDON.
JUST THIS YEAR 98 KNOWN
TERRORISTS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE CAUGHT.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
RACHEL: WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
MORE -- THIS IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
WHY ISN'T THIS TOP NEWS?
>> IT IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE AND THAT'S WHAT'S SO
FRUSTRATING TO ALL BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND WE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND SEE
IT EVERY SINGLE DAY AND SHOULD
BE DEALING WITH 30 TO 40
APPREHENSIONS PER MONTH AND
TYPICALLY THAT'S SINGLE ADULTS
AND NOT FAMILY UNITS AND NOT
CHILDREN BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
OUR HANDS ARE COMPLETELY TIED
AND SO THE SMUGGLERS ARE ABLE TO
GET ACROSS ANYTHING THEY WANT TO
GET ACROSS WHETHER THAT'S
FENTANYL OR LIKE YOU JUST SAID
PEOPLE FROM SPECIAL INTEREST
COUNTRIES THAT WANT TO DO US
HARM.
THIS BORDER SECURITY CRISIS
COULD BE SOLVED TOMORROW AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS NO
POLITICAL ROLE AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHO'S COMING IN AND WHAT HARM IS
BEING DONE AND IT'LL BE FELT
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD AND WE'LL
LOOK AND COULD HAVE BEEN SOLVED
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WANTED TO PANDER TO POLITICS AND
PLACE THE CALL AND PEOPLE
LAUGHED AT HIM AND WE NOW KNOW
IT'S TRUE AND IT'S NOT MAKING
BIG NEWS OUTSIDE OF FOX AND IT'S
AMAZING TO ME AND I WANT TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT THE CARTELS AND
LAST TIME WE HAD YOU ON, YOU HAD
A JAW DROPPING INTERVIEW WITH A
CARTEL MEMBER, I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU GOT ACCESS, IT WAS AMAZING.
PEOPLE SHOULD WATCH YOUR PODCAST
BECAUSE YOU DO A GREAT JOB.
YOU -- CARTEL MEMBERS SAID THAT
IT ISN'T JUST CHILD HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, SEX TRAFFICKING, HE
TALKED ABOUT THE SALE OF CHILD
ORGANS.
I MEAN, THIS IS SOME DARK EVIL
STUFF, AND WE ARE NOW EMPOWERING
THE CARTELS THAT THEY'RE MORE
POWERFUL THAN EVER.
>> THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
WHEN I'M ON THE BORDER OR TRAVEL
TO CENTRAL AMERICA, WHEN I TALK
TO THE PEOPLE, YOU'RE RIGHT, I
DID GET ACCESS TO A COYOTE, A
SMUGGLER AND HE WAS HIGHER LEVEL
BECAUSE HE WAS IN EL SALVADOR
AND HIS STORY IS NOT JUST ABOUT
MOVING PEOPLE ACROSS THREE
COUNTRIES INTO THE UNITED STATES
BUT TAKING CHILDREN BUT CARTELS
IN MEXICO ARE LITERALLY TAKING A
LOT OF CHILDREN.
THEY'RE HARVESTING THEIR ORGANS
AND THEY'RE USING THEM IN THE
MOST HORRIFIC WAYS IMAGINABLE.
I WAS ABLE TO VERIFY THIS
THROUGH DEA AND U.S.
INTELLIGENCE AND WHAT ARE WE
DOING HERE AND WHY IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ALLOWING THIS TO
HAPPEN AND IN FACT IT IS THEIR
POLICY.
WHY ARE THEY EMBOLDENED.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> LOOKING AT PEOPLE WITH OUR
TAX DOLLARS INTO THE INTERIOR.
>> THE INTERIOR WITH THE KNOWN
GOT AWAYS AND THE CRIMINALS, I
KNOW BRANDON AND I SPEND TIME ON
THE BORDER ALL THE TIME AND THIS
IS A SERIOUS SITUATION AND HE'S
HAD 20,000, 20,000 TO 30,000 A
MONTH.
NOW 230,000 A MONTH.
RACHEL: BRANDON, ONCE THE
CHILDREN ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDES
AND OUTSIDE OF THE DETENTION
CENTER AND THE GOVERNMENT IS
LOSING TRACK OF 40% OF THE
CHILDREN THAT WERE PROCESSED.
THIS IS A CRIME.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE THAT THIS
IS NOT FRONT PAGE NEWS.
>> IT IS AND EVERY SINGLE TIME A
BORDER PATROL AGENT TAKES THE
INDIVIDUAL INTO CUSTODY, I HAD
SENATOR TUBERVILLE ON THE BORDER
YESTERDAY AND HE GOT TO SEE
EXACTLY WHAT IS COMING ACROSS.
HE GOT TO SEE THE CHILDREN IN
CUSTODY AND WHENEVER WE TAKE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS INTO CUSTODY,
WE SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM.
WE FEEL IT AND TO KNOW THIS
ADMINISTRATION ISN'T DOING
ANYTHING TO PROTECT THESE
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS, THESE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN THAT ARE
BEING BECAUSED AND RAPED --
ABUSED AND RAPED AND SOMETIMES
EVEN MURDERED IN MEXICO ON THEIR
JOURNEY AND YOU HAPPEN DOING
NOTHING TO STOP THIS AND, AGAIN,
RACHEL, THERE'S SOLUTIONS BUT
THEY WON'T PUT THEM INTO PLACE.
>> WE HAD A PANEL --
RACHEL: IT WAS A PANEL YESTERDAY
AND PIECE HANDOUT ICKS AND
WHITES -- HISPANICS AND WHITES
AND DEMOCRATS AND ASKED THEM IF
THEY THOUGHT THE BORDER WAS OPEN
AND ALL RAISED THEIR HAND
SAYING, YES, THE BORDER IS OPEN.
THEN SEIZURE DISORDERED IF THEY
THOUGHT THE BIDEN POLICY WAS
INTENTIONAL AND THEY ALL RAISED
THEIR HAND, DEMOCRATS INCLUDED.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS POLICY
AND WE'LL HAVE TO HAVE YOU GUYS
BACK BECAUSE THIS -- IT'S
CRIMINAL WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR
COUNTRY AND THE INNOCENT VICTIMS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND ALL THE
CHILDREN OUT THERE LOST AND ONES
THAT HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES,
IMAGINE WHAT THAT'S LIKE FOR
THEM.
RACHEL: THANK YOU, GUYS, FOR
BOTH COVERING TH